oh my gosh today is going to be such an
exciting day let's
go first stop we got to get breakfast
tacos I have to park better you're not
in Focus there you are you're in Focus I
have to park better
no got the goods oh oh oh oh do I get a
speaker in mine too a what a speaker
miles and then I was also thinking we
could get the tent and then like we both
can use it what if we both get the tent
how much are the tent like 3,000 okay
we're going to get one tent okay we're
going to play music
now I need to bring anything like any
documents um so it's just right here oh
I'm sorry we're waiting for delivery I
signed the document and the document I
actually signed I signed it too many
times so we had to go print a new one I
didn't listen to directions but we're
waiting
[Music]
patiently can I get
it oh it's so nice would you like me to
give you the torque sick sure Jen what
do we got where's our flashlight and
where's our the flashlight is over here
in the door oh I like the white steering
wheel yeah the white is nice so the
speaker will be
underneath
this is important I like this be want to
put this stuff here that is nice I'm s
okay I'm my delivery wo and then click
on the car icon there you are there's
there's there's me yeah you can adjust
your seat right now yeah boost up if you
want to tap your foot on the brake it
will loosen up the oh that's nice okay
such a nice process the interface looks
so good a second there it is there we go
push set up now foone key is paired
sweet we are so these are your physical
Keys you get a key fob o I love little
carer one for you s is there m yeah that
is cool that's something we added
recently with software I just like that
there's a front camera why is there not
a front camera on Tesla like it doesn't
it makes no sense I 100% agree with
remember I told you that someone told me
well you don't need a front camera
because you have eyes that is the worst
argument that I've ever heard and look
you have this lovely overhead which I
use to park all the time is there a
heated steering wheel oh yeah
okay good it'll be in your settings here
I keep my heating steer wheel on even in
the middle of summer oh boy where's Gary
there he is he is look at him he's
vlogging look at this you stand on it if
you want and you can get in there's an
emergency
release there you go dude what are you
going to do up there nothing oh there's
120 volt plug just in case dude this is
great like this is where I could sleep
instead of getting the tent no round of
on I mean you can do whatever you
want I mean yeah this is wonderful this
is
wonderful look that little trick you
just did I don't think I'll be doing
that too often but just good to know
good you have options where's the
emergency latch uh it's a b right here
yep cool it glows in the dark too nice I
never actually saw anyone go through
theel here we are thank you thank you
I'll be here for the next 15 minutes
so now you can fit look at that yeah
it's automatic it drop okay cool
nice so there's space under here too yep
oh that's yeah that's big oh that is big
okay so I can put my tire in there or
you have a drain down there too so you
can make this a big ice chest back here
or also in the front as well
so Boom ni that's it yeah is the gear
guard cable so this is SL resistant for
knives and whatnot to keep all your gear
safe these two ends go right into the
back over here next to the air
compressor when you plug these into
place and you tie all your gear down
you're not going to have to worry about
people slashing this rope here and then
your air compressor is here nice and
then over here I don't know if you saw
there's secret compartment is I was just
going to ask where's the there it is so
this is for the air compressor this
gives you a hose which will reach all
four of your
tires oh my gosh I can refill my own air
you don't have to go to gas station no
more this is great what are you doing
what's this that's your portable charger
give you a 110 volt and a 240 volt
adapter m M it's magnetic as well there
you go I'm learning and pipes very nice
ready for an adventure what's your first
Adventure going to I'm going to go to
7-Eleven this is how we open to
charge do I not do that no you swipe it
again oh sorry oh my
God wa more storage and then your cup
holders are right here okay we need
those that's important you have like
pass through storage to the Gear tunnel
so like if you put like a water bottle I
I didn't know about C thing yeah I
didn't either that's great that is
nice see storage so cool this is a very
nice flashlight it is yeah they must
have gone through a lot of research to
be like how do we make the best
flashlight do you want to see my speaker
Jenna's like I've seen all of these
things it's great cuz like I went to an
Airbnb and I didn't have a speaker any
we had the bonfire remember we had a
bonfire and Jenna got her speaker out
now it's time to do some accessory
shopping all right so this is it I guess
we we drive well I drive you drove me
here in your movy should I started up
well I mean it's not going to do it's
not going to do a big Ral there it is do
you want to see me pull forward and then
pull back
[Music]
again how' I do pretty good did you use
your
cameras I don't know what I did I just
went forward and backwards woo uh
welcome to the new rivy I would love to
hear in the comments below what kind of
access should I do should I do some tint
should I do a wrap should I get it
wrapped pink I don't know maybe I think
I'll probably keep the white for a while
because it looks so so good stay tuned
for more bye thanks for filming Jenna
y